Honduras is one of the poorest countries
in Central and South America but there's
a new idea about to be tried in Honduras
it's called as ed a privately run zone
with legal economic and political
autonomy the laws are all in place
investors are lined up and ready to go
and the big questions about to be
answered will this actually work my name
is Gabriel Delgado I'm the CEO of
elevator city's company that's looking
to take advantage of jurisdiction past
in Honduras that creates a special area
that different laws and different system
can be brought in do we want to be one
of the top five cities in the world in
30 years this is solving problems at a
much larger scale to bring a lot of
opportunities to people that right now
just currently don't have them the best
scenario for the Honduran zez is that it
becomes a demonstration of how we can
install a new legal system with much
higher quality rule of law and economic
freedom so that we can create a hong
kong of honduras pizzette legislation
allows firms to implement their own
commercial and civil law in the zones
and Delgada believes that elevator
city's unique approach will make or
break their startup city our competitive
advantage is our legal system I sell you
my car what I promised you I was going
to deliver on what I actually delivered
you were two completely different things
you don't even have to go to a lawyer to
do anything you just go into the
software and click on that you want to
run arbitration on this contract that
contract is gonna be what's called a
smart contract
it's basically what's called day of
baseball arbitration where you choose
your arbiter I choose mine they choose a
common one then he looks at all the data
and then he issues the judgment also
loser pays damages because we're trying
to do this as organic as possible and
what we believe is gonna happen is much
what has happened in the history of the
world people go where it's easier to get
things done simple as that the law
permits companies to levy taxes in the
zones but caps federal taxes and allows
flexibility in methods of political
representation we
think the market is important the thing
is how do you create a system where
people can't vote themselves more and
more privileges as time goes by it's
actually whoever owns a share that
actually gets to vote you could get a
share if you incorporate a business or
you can get a share if you owned a piece
of land so there's different ways of
becoming a shareholder the opt-in nature
of the project is really the key to the
whole thing because you're not
compelling anybody by force to come here
you are showing people the opportunity
and they choose to come so it's gonna
fail or succeed on its own merits the
biggest challenge that Honduran startup
cities face are perhaps those of safety
in one of the most violent countries in
the world while the zones must divide by
Honduran criminal law they can provide
their own police and security forces so
you can create a zone where there's a
security force that isn't the government
security force police in your area much
like a homeowner's association again so
that generates us a serious increase in
the security situation for families that
are subject to violence people will most
likely move if there is opportunity plus
security so I think that's what we're
trying to provide the first zones will
likely be approved in the next several
months and only then will the world
begin to see with competing autonomous
jurisdictions are a far-fetched fantasy
or a practical tool to fix a broken
system that's often seemed beyond repair
it takes people to really dream to be
able to get one of these things done I
really want more people to dream with us
about this I walk about what the
affected this can have in the world so
if this can be made to work and attract
investment and resolve all of the other
potential issues I expect to see in the
next 10 to 20 years
literally first dozens and eventually
perhaps hundreds of similar experiments
around the world that will accelerate
the end of poverty more rapidly than
anything anyone can imagine